it can be hard to make rational sense of
the world but is your brain your own
worst enemy here are four of the many
ways your brains processing shortcuts
are playing tricks on you
welcome to cognitive bias understanding
a bit about it could change the way you
see the world so here goes
a recent peer-reviewed scientific study
found caffeine consumption is strongly
linked with developing cancer on this
scale to what extent do you agree or
disagree with the findings of this study
relax
this study is fake however your answer
will be directly influenced by the
amount of caffeine you drink cognitive
bias number one self-serving bias
self-serving bias is your brains strong
natural tendency to interpret
information in such a way as to unduly
favor itself in this experiment caffeine
drinkers rated the study's validity
consistently lower than non caffeine
drinkers subjects with a negative
personal stake in the outcome of
research were less convinced by the data
how irrational your brain will reject
perfectly viable information simply
because it has negative implications for
your personal beliefs and behaviors
likewise it will tend to eagerly accept
information with positive implications
even if that information is flawed or
inconclusive so why does your brain do
this self-serving bias protects ones
fragile ego from threat and injury that
last group presentation you gave was
either a success thanks to your
brilliant work or was a failure thanks
to everyone else you got to look after
that ego okay a new thought experiment
look at this parking what do you think
of the red cars driver if you thought
poorly of the drivers character you have
performed cognitive bias number two
fundamental attribution error this is
your brains attempt to explain behavior
by placing undue emphasis on internal
characteristics of the person
rather than external factors consider
that just moments ago these cars were
parked in a way that left the red cars
driver with little option does that
change your opinion fundamental
attribution error is often performed
when driving I'm speeding because I'm in
a rush whereas they're speeding because
they're an inconsiderate maniac your
brain has limited capacity to interpret
the world it can observe the badly
parked car and understand that someone
puts it there but that's it to theorize
about the historical arrangement of the
cars or the situational needs of the
driver is a complex and potentially
unending use of finite cognitive
resources on to the next one here's a
famous experiment by Peter wastin play
along at home subjects were given a
three number sequence told that it
follows a simple rule and asked to
figure out the rule they were allowed to
suggest their own number sequences and
told to continue until they were
confident that they had cracked the rule
were you thinking of a sequence like
this this follows the rule and another
something like this this also follows
the rule so what is the rule it's two
multiplied by two right well no your
brain just performed another cognitive
bias confirmation bias the actual rule
is any sequence of numbers in ascending
order so what went wrong your brain
landed on its first type offices
multiplied by two from there every
suggested number sequence was used to
confirm that initial hypothesis rather
than actually test it a rational
approach would be to attempt to disprove
this hypothesis by suggesting other
number sequences that didn't follow it
but your brain isn't rational it has a
tendency to search for interpret favor
and recall information that confirms its
pre-existing beliefs numbers or
otherwise confirmation bias is
based on limitations in the brain's
ability to handle complex tasks and the
shortcuts that it uses as a result the
brain finds it really difficult to test
alternative hypotheses in parallel it's
good but it's not that good ok so you've
learned a few cognitive biases you're
now prepared to combat them in your own
brain after all knowing is half the
battle right well not exactly
that's cognitive bias number four the GI
Joe fallacy the action figure and TB
character GI Joe famously said knowing
is half the battle when it comes to
cognitive bias he was well out knowing
is one thing but habits situations and
other processes still rule the roost
self-awareness won't beat it you may
know what a badly parked car does not
make a bad person but you'll still feel
negatively towards them you may know
your brain will take shortcuts to
confirm the hypotheses it already holds
but it will still take those shortcuts
you may know that your brain will
protect your ego at every turn but the
ego security will still be out in force
so knowing about cognitive biases is way
less than half the battle even knowing
the GI Joe fallacy about knowing about
combative biases is still way less than
half the battle funny how your brain can
pontificate about its own limitations
but do almost nothing about them but in
the true spirit of cognitive bias you
will be able to point it out in others
good luck with that
you